وزير الخارجيه الصينيه شين جانج عن قلق
بلاده الشديد من تفاقم الوضع في اوكرانيا
الذي قد يخرج عن السيطره على حد تعبيره
واضاف الوزير الصيني ان بلاده ستعمل مع
المجتمع الدولي من اجل تعزيز الحوار
والتشاور ومعالجه مخاوف كل الاطراف وشدد
على موقف بلاده الثابت والملتزم
بالموضوعيه وتعزيز المحادثات بين اطراف
النزاع
من جهته قلال المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه من الولايات المتحده
تواصل نشر ما سماها معلومات كاذبه عن
مساعدات عسكريه صينيه الى روسيا واضاف ان
بيجين لا تقبل لن تنتقد واشنطن العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه مضيفه ان شركتها مع موسكو
قيمه على عدم المواجهه وعدم استهداف دول
اخرى
ووصفت الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده
بانها اكبر مصدر للاسلحه في ساحه الحرب
باوكرانيا واشارت الى ان الصين وروسيا
تلعبان دورا ايجابيا في السلام العالمي
وشددت الوزاره على ان زياره رئيس اللجنه
المركزيه للشؤون الخارجيه الصينيه الى
موسكو هدفها تعزيز علاقات ومصالح البلدين
تنشر الولايات المتحده معلومات كاذبه حول
امدادات الصين لروسيا من الاسلحه وتستمر
في القول انها تسعى الى الحفاظ على السلام
لكنها في الحقيقه تحقق ثروه من الحرب لقد
جنت الصناعه العسكريه الامريكيه اموالا
كثيره من ساحه المعركه الاوكرانيه لا نقبل
ابدا ان تنتقد واشنطن العلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه او حتى تكرهها او تضغط عليها
فالصين ملتزمه بالحوار
وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قد جدد
مخاوف بلاده والمجتمع الدولي من احتمال ان
تزود الصين روسيا باسلحه فتاكه لاستخدامها
في الحرب على اوكرانيا وقال في تغريده على
تويتر اليوم من دول حلف الناتو قدمت دعما
غير مسبوق الى اوكرانيا منذ بدء ما سماه
حرب بوتين العدوانيه وغير القانونيه واكد
بلنكن في تغريده على تويتر بمناسبه اقتراب
الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب ان دول الحلف
ستبقى متحده مع اوكرانيا لاطول فتره ممكنه